They're begging.
Doc is called after the,
uh,
Manassian bagans Israeli prime minister
order to strike the Iraqi reactor.
Tommaso ciroc back in 1981.
Basically,
the begging doc doctrine says that
Israel would never accept the fact that
a hostile country that calls for it's
destructions,
destructions holds the means to deliver
this,
this sort of operation,
meaning Israel would never tolerate the
existent of nuclear power in the hands
of,
of a hostile country like Syria or Iran.
And you can draw your conclusions from
that.
That if worst comes to worst as a very
last resort,
if Israel is convinced that the
International Boyko doesn't work,
that Russia and China do not align with
the rest of the world,
that economic sanctions do not pressure
Iran enough that the United States is
not going to take action and Iran is
getting too close to close to enable
them.
Israel with strike Iran.
And I can tell you that long,
not long ago,
a few weeks ago in,
uh,
in,
classify discussion dealing with the
Iranian issue,
there's a special form of the Israeli
decision and intelligence,
uh,
operatives dealing with Iran.
One of them said that if worse comes to
worse,
we must bear in mind what the Israeli
first Prime Minister David been going
and said repeatedly that we did not
bring the survivors of the Holocaust to
Israel to suffer another,
another holocaust,
and we would do everything but
everything to prevent them.
[inaudible].